Now we've seen how useful preprocessing can be for a variety of problems.
So, let's look at some possible preprocessing rules
that we could use for the shortest tour problem.
Now what I'd like you to tell me about each of the preprocessing rules
is whether they are correct;
that is, they don't change the solution outcome to something different
than they would be if you didn't apply the rule,
and are they effective, meaning they don't increase the size of the input
and actually make your job harder.
So the first possibility is that we could calculate the shortest path
from each vertex to each other vertex,
and then we remove all of the unused edges.
The second possibility is that, as long as the graph stays connected,
we could just remove the heaviest edges and repeat until the graph disconnects
and don't remove that one.
The third possibility is remove any edge that has a larger weight
than the minimum spanning tree's weight.
Finally, we could replace long paths by a single edge that has equal weight.
So, go ahead and check which ones you think are correct
and which rules you think are also effective.